sensation sensations le mag
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur
sensation en partenariat avec tv 60,18
je suis aujourd'hui avec jean daniel
laval directeur du théâtre de fontenay
le fleury bonjour bonjour or depuis
quelques depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant les théâtres peuvent
reprendre leur programmation comment
s'est passée la réouverture du théâtre
de fontenay le fleury alors pour être
très honnête au niveau du cinéma n'a
jamais fermé puisque on va quand même
travaillé tout l'été
la réouverture sera le dise donc on peut
pas dire s'il y aura une grande présence
du public en revanche il ya mon attitude
à moi est de dire que contrairement à ce
qu'on peut entendre dans les médias je
crois pas que les gens vont à coup de
trompette de s'enthousiasmer venir en
courant en applaudissant des trois mains
je crois franchement que on est dans une
situation de convalescence dans les
esprits des gens je crois qu'ils sont
encore fragiles sont encore dans
l'inquiétude et le questionnement donc
nous on a fait le choix de faire une
rentrée plutôt en douceur calme sereine
et puis surtout très individuel c'était
qu'on essaye d'aller reprendre les gens
par la main comme on faisait à l'époque
pour amener du monde et donc voilà par
le biais de tout ce que le monde moderne
nous offrent les newsletters choses
comme ça on va pas travailler sur le
fait de remplir à tout prix la salle qui
en plus de ça et de toute façon
fait d'une moitié de jauge puisque nous
avions au précédent que vit d'organiser
la salle pour accueillir comme c'était
obligatoire la moitié de juin et alors
avant de parler de la programmation
pouvez vous nous détailler vos ambitions
pour cette nouvelle saison l'ambition
je pense qu'il faut que les gens
retrouvent le chemin d'un apaisement
plus que d'un plus que dans d'éclats de
rire d'une joie d'une solidarité tout ça
je pense qu'il ya vraiment besoin
d'apaiser vous savez quand vous sortez
de l'hôpital après avoir pris un grand
coup dans les dents d'une opération
quelconque que vous n'avez pas envie
forcément de tout de suite attaqué les
steaks frites et des joies et le
champagne quoi vous êtes surtout dans
une position un petit peu humble où vous
dites je vais me reconstruire et donc je
pense que et alors il ya quelque chose
très positif pour moi je parle pour moi
seul et de façon égoïste c'est que j'ai
l'impression de me retrouver dans la
situation des premières années quand
j'ai eu mon premier théâtre c'est
reconquérir un public l'on peut
découvrir lors trouver voilà ça c'est je
trouve ça extrêmement positif surtout
que je suis à deux ans de la fin donc je
trouve que commencer une retraite par un
début de carrière c'est pas mal alors
justement au niveau de la programmation
les 10 et 11 septembre la saison démarre
avec le dindon d'après feydeau de la
compagnie les nomadesk que pensez vous
de cette pièce de théâtre pourquoi la
proposer aux spectateurs je la propose
pas ce que parce que d'abord c'est
l'équipe des nomadesk qu'on connaît très
bien qu'on déjà ceux qui jouent presque
chaque année avec nous pour des
spectacles pour enfants pour des
spectacles adultes ils font partie de ma
compagnie d'origine c'est une comment
dirais-je une thérapie l'équipe b se
serait pas très gentil promet une équipe
à à bissau va dire et donc c'est des
copains c'est des amis et que et j'avais
besoin de gens ce vraiment simple qui
ramène un petit peu de plus de joie que
de théâtre ou de houe de chefs-d'oeuvre
vous savez tout le monde veut montrer
son chef-d'oeuvre je préfère des gens
qui montrent une
humanité en fait et c'est très humain
c'est drôle le fait que ce soit drôle
c'est pas forcément mon ambition
première tant mieux si c'est drôle mais
les émotions de pleurs et de qatar sival
autant que le rire non pour moi j'ai pas
de
deux choses précises à ce sujet à dire
mais sinon que voilà le dindon s'est
fait dos et bus et une base assez
classique ça bon classique bien sympa
qui ne brusque aura personne et le 17
septembre les spectateurs pourront
découvrir une pièce de théâtre qui a
reçu le grand prix du théâtre 2021 la
pièce s'appelle la force du coquelicot
justement qu'est ce qui fait la force de
cette pièce de théâtre bah je crois que
ces deux personnages c'est très sensible
ces
jeux pas spoiler l'histoire parce que
c'est au tour mais c'est beau tour d'un
vélo une jeune fille qui a un accident
sur un virage qui rencontre un homme et
il ya quelque chose de l'ordre de
de l'ecoute qui m'intéressent quoi
c'était à ne pas être dans le bluff ne
pas être dans la lah la violence des
situations pour pour essayer de séduire
enfin c'est quelque chose de très en
douceur assez poétique en fait j'aime
bien la poésie savoir son charme et puis
c'est un concours de théâtre doc c'est
c'est un choix qui a été fait par un
jury vous savez un jury landa dedans il
y avait des enseignants ddd comment dire
des gens de la profession
l'entreprise choses comme ça ils ont
fait ce choix voilà c'est leur choix on
va passer au 24 septembre maintenant
avec jean claude drouot qui incarne
victor hugo un grand auteur du 19e
siècle la pièce s'appelle l'art d'être
grand-père or comment se compose la
pièce alors je serais trop vous dire
parce que c'est quand même un texte un
texte poétique de victor hugo c'est pas
une oeuvre dramatique en revanche c'est
la parole d'un homme que je connais bien
jean-claude on se connaît depuis des
années c'est un homme qui a eu des
théâtres qui a été même directeur du
théâtre national de bruxelles de
belgique veut dire qu'il t'est la
colonie française et ça se trouve ce
sont des carrières assez admirable parce
que c'est les carrières finalement qui
se font dans la comme disait bouquet
dans l'artisanat et non pas dans le
caractère artistes et c'est un artisan
du théâtre et je trouve que il a un âge
où le texte de victor hugo va bien avec
et son physique et sa personnalité donc
je pense que je sais pas après ce que ce
qu'est le spectacle pour être très
honnête je n'ai pas vu je fais confiance
à l'artiste et à celle envers son choix
artistiques en revanche je sais une
chose c'est que s'asseoir et écouter ses
belles voix chaude
rassurantes avec un personnage qui a
presque jean-claude il doit approcher le
centre 15 ans où 117 ch pas je connais
pas son âge précis et
ça fait du bien ça fait du bien toujours
dans l'esprit de la forêt les sens
toujours dans l'esprit de faire du bien
justement à baliser un bien venez vous
faire du bien cette thérapeutique et le
2 octobre la compagnie zigomatik jouera
son spectacle climax le spectacle parle
de entre autres l'actualité des
problèmes environnementaux à travers un
discours comique c'est donc un spectacle
humoristique mais dénonciateurs oui
enfin dénonciateur je dirais pas
forcément ça mais je dirais en tout cas
c'est un spectacle intelligent et qui en
plus ça peut apporter traite d'un sujet
de façon un peu humoristique légère
musical chanté joyeuse et c'est parce
que nous sommes dans la semaine de
l'environnement à ce moment là
qui a été déplacé à cause du coc vide
donc en général c'est au printemps est
là ils ont déplacé en octobre et qu'on a
voulu dans la ville on essaye de tout
l'est tous les événements de la ville on
essaye de s'y associer d'une certaine
manière alors ne pas forcément
d'intégrer leurs projets mais de d'être
en parallèle toujours jamais à
contre-courant dit jamais à contretemps
donc voila c'était dans cette idée là et
du 6 au 12 octobre vous organisez un
escape game au sein du théâtre de
fontenay le fleury comment s'organise
7,7 escape game est ce qu'il ya une
intrigue oui alors le trick videmment
autour de mots rien faut il toujours pas
ce que c'est sherlock holmes mais on
avait déjà fait l'expérience dans une
des salles du théâtre avec une seule
pièce
qui était bureau de mon art et qui avait
très bien marché et comme je sais que
les gars qui ont fait 7
cette pièce là avait fait dans un camion
semi-remorque eu un escape game qui dure
50 minutes sur trois pièces différentes
on s'est dit bon puisque ça marche bien
on va m'en va monter d'un cran et on va
proposer cette version là c'est vraiment
franchement j'encourage les gens qui
aiment les scripts même devenir ça fait
partie du haut de gamme france
finalement le spectateur devient un
petit peu acteur une certaine c'est
surtout même enfermée dans des villes
est plus qu acteur ce qui peut pas
sortir parfois la solution non non non
elle le supplie au téléphone sortez moi
d'ailleurs c'est drôle pour la petite
aigles d'autres appuis je me suis
retrouvé mois enfermé dans une cage à la
fin et j'avais rendez-vous et j'étais là
je disais mais sûreté moi j'ai rendez
vous donc c'était l'horreur mais ils ont
voulu finalement oui je pense qu'ils
vont sortir et le 15 octobre la
compagnie barda plume sera en
représentation au théâtre de fontenay le
fleury pour son spectacle séisme alors
de quoi parle cette pièce alors ça parle
d'un couple qui s'interroge sur la
nécessité le besoin l'envi de faire un
enfant et voire même les troubles les
inquiétudes et angoisse qui peuvent
avoir à l'égard de faire cet enfant
franchement je vais vous dire un truc
moi je vais pas trop voir les spectacles
parce que je m'appuie sur des choses
relativement solide que son je connais
le met en scène je connais un des
acteurs donc je sais que ce sont des
gens qui savent plus ou moins lire les
textes donc je me dis semaine 7 cet
agencement entre cet acteur ce metteur
en scène plus ce texte ça devrait faire
un bon résultat c'est comme ça que je
travaille parce que j'ai pas le temps de
sortir tous les soirs évidemment je fais
partie des gens qui travaillent sur le
terrain et non pas forcément qui se
balade de deux salles de théâtre en
salle de théâtre et là j'y suis allé
parce que c'est un ancien élève à moi
qui est sorti du conservatoire de
versailles à trois quatre ans j'avais vu
une première version d'un trail qu'il
avait fait était tellement point de vue
épouvantable j'étais vraiment effondré
je lui ai dit d'ailleurs j'écoute là je
comprends rien de ce que tu m'as fait
j'y suis allé vraiment à reculons et je
suis tombé sur une perle une vraie perle
deux jeunes c'est quand on est quand on
à mon agent n'est pas toujours sensibles
aux jeunes un paf même si enfin c'est
toujours hypocrite moi je suis j'aime la
jeunesse a toujours merde le jeu n'est
ce pas voilà c'est trop rapide trop vite
ça réfléchit pas là je suis en plus
c'était une sale improbable sur des
chaises en skaï c'était vraiment un truc
bizarre et je suis tombé sur un petit
chef-d'oeuvre donc je me suis je leur ai
dit ce que je fais jamais je leur ai dit
écoutez là vous venez là vous venez moi
je veux je m'en fiche du public ou pas
au fond
je serais ravi ici à du public pour mais
je veux qui sait qu'ils expérimentent
cette pièce sur une grande scène dans un
vrai théâtre voilà ça a été un coup dur
finalement à webo complet mais la pièce
formidable et pis les deux jeunes ils
m'ont scotché j'en suis presque devenu
jaloux en mesure merde quand même y en a
qui ont du talent ces casses pieds et
vous êtes fier en quelques mots de cette
programmation justement que vous
proposez pour septembre et octobre si
fier
écoutez je vais vous décevoir je vais
jouer prétentieux je suis assez fier
chaque cas bébé affamé la fière alors il
ya deux sentiments c'est à dire je suis
fier mais je m'interroge toujours je me
refais stion
voilà je me dis ça y est vous c'est très
bizarre quand vous faites la
programmation vous dit c'est génial
parce que dans l'élan deux mois après
vous dites à peut-être que j'aurais pas
dû ça j'aurais pas dû ça six mois après
mais même quand la programmation et en
automne c'est ce que j'ai bien fait
d'avoir fait ça c est à vous c'est une
remise en question franchement qui est
utile moi je vais vous dire quand on
voit franchement vous pouvez être fiers
merci joubert
sensations on peut se rendre sur votre
site théâtre de fontenay point fr pour
plus d'informations et pour revoir ou
réécouter cette émission rendez vous sur
notre site et applications radio
sensations
[Musique]